All right. So my talk is focused on cilta cell efficacy, safety, and the questions we still need to answer. I think based on the data presented by Dr. Jaganath, Dr. Wuhi, and during ASCO, we are potentially witnessing the first curative therapy in multiple myeloma.
The word cure is pretty hard for me to say, but I'm learning to say it. But we still have many unanswered questions in terms of who are these patients that we're selecting, who will end up getting this cure, how do we prevent harm and decrease treatment-related mortality, and where it belongs in the treatment continuum as we get bispecifics and dual CAR-Ts and all these other novel agents that are in development.
All right. This is my talk.
This is my disclosures. So these are the graphs for overall survival and progression-free survival from cilta cell, which was done in a heavily pre-treated patient population, overall response rates close to 97.9%, with stringency R rates of 82.5%, and a median survival of 60.7 months.
And one in three patients were disease-free, that means MRD-negative and PET-negative at five years in a patient population where overall survival...
And one in three patients were disease-free, that means MRD-negative and PET-negative at five years in a patient population where overall survival was roughly around 11 months.
So that's a remarkable achievement that we've had based due to this therapy.
And then, so how do we predict responders?
The biology of long responders, is it disease burden? Is it T-cell fitness?
Because if you can see on this table over here, when it comes to EMD, we always talk about EMD as a big risk factor for patients not doing well, not responding to therapy.
And you can see over here that that number was comparable in both of these groups.
The high tumor burden can go along with extramedullary disease, but that was much higher in 17.4% of the patients than the ones who had more than a five-year response.
And also, the T-cell fitness.
So we noted that in the patients who were, the 33% of the patients, there was higher naive T-cell fraction in the drug product.
There was lower tumor burden at baseline.
There was higher effective to target.
Ratio when it comes to, and then also CD4 central memory CAR-T-cells were higher.
So ultimately, patients benefited regardless of high-risk cytogenetics or EMD, which is what we conventionally think of as when we stratify.
I mean, even now, when I have to decide a patient who's going to get first, second-line CAR-T, who are the patients I'm prioritizing?
The ones who have high-risk cytogenetics, the ones who have EMD.
But maybe we have to like twist it around and start thinking more about the T-cell biology.
But we have to think about the T-cell biology.
But we're not really there yet, and I think that's where our field has to go.
And then, so we take from, we go from CAR T1 to CAR T4, and most of us are familiar with the trial schema, and you can oversee over here that, you know, CAR-T, in comparison to standard of care, which was PVD or DPD in this trial, you know, killed it in terms of their PFS, as well as their overall survival rates.
And this was, this benefit was seen across a number of patients.
And I think that's what we try to do.
That's the art of medicine, and that's what we strive to do every single day.
So then we go to CAR T2, and, you know, many of us are familiar with the different cohorts where it was done in early relapse, patients who were functionally high-risk.
But I think I want to pay attention to the cohort C, which is post-PCMA, right, whether they were bispecific or ADC-exposed.
And you can see all the wonderful numbers that I showed you from CAR T1.
Those numbers over here don't really measure up.
We see a significant decline in terms of their PFS.
And that's where the field is getting complicated, because we do have TECDARA and other bispecifics that are coming in earlier and earlier.
Okay.
Real-world data where we have cilta-cel versus IDA-cel that was done, the work was done by the U.S. Myeloma Immunotherapy Consortium.
Dr. Hansen published, you know, cilta-cel efficacy higher, but then toxicity also higher.
And then...
Dr. Surbhi Sidhana published on the -- from the Immunotherapy Consortium, cilta-cel patients who were standard care cilta-cel with patients who had six prior lines of therapy, 54% of those patients would have not qualified for CAR T1, 14 had prior BCMA therapy.
And you saw that the patients had 89% overall response rate, but then there was a high percentage of patients who had non-conforming product.
And this may have been because this was early on in the era of commercial CAR-T launch.
When there was a lot of wait time and delayed, you know, long manufacturing periods, but most recently, there was an abstract that was published at -- presented at Tandem that showed the significance of the -- I want to highlight that, that if patients did not respond to bridging therapy during their manufacturing time, the risk of Parkinsonism goes up 10 times higher.
So that's something we have to keep in mind as we take patients to these therapies in the real world.
And, of course, you know, CRS and ICANNs, which I think is one of the most important things that we need to keep in mind as we take patients to these therapies in the real world.
And, of course, you know, CRS and ICANNs, which I think is what the patients get worried about, but as a clinician who takes care of these patients, I'm not really worried about CRS and ICANNs because I think we -- the patients are in the hospital or in your outpatient program.
We -- by 10 years into CAR-T, we know how to manage CRS and ICANNs.
It's the HLH, it's the delayed -- it's the delayed neurotoxicities, whether it's Parkinsonism, how to detect it, you know, or the peripheral neuropathies and GBS, and now even IEC collagen.
I don't think we have clear direction.
All institutions are doing something different in terms of being mindful and picking these up.
I think this is what is going to dictate how much cilta cell gets adopted and whether patients delay it.
And second line from third line, I have 19 seconds, so I'll try to get through.
And, of course, we've seen case reports that are published when it comes to actually CAR-positive T-cell lymphoma.
All of them are in the New England Journal of Medicine, so I'm not going to go into the details.
I'm not going to go into the details of that because that's beyond the scope of my talk, but you can see that, you know, this has been described not just with cilta cell, but also with other CAR products as well.
And then, of course, I think today's dilemma is how does -- although we are saying we don't want to get patients -- we want to give CAR-T before bispecifics, that's what I feel as well, but I think as bispecifics will become readily available in the community,
so we're going to brace for a space where most of our patients will become BCM-exposed by the time we get them, and then we're going to learn how to take them to CAR-T.
So on that note, my clinical conclusions, the cure conversation is real.
It is no longer hypothetical, and nobody's going to tell you to get off the podium when you mention that word.
The T-cell fitness predicts cure, not disease risk.
I think there is an argument to move cilta cell earlier to give patients treatment independence time and time toxicity.
I think CAR-T before BCMA bispecifics is a good idea.
CAR-T before BCMA bispecifics makes sense, although accessibility for patients is a factor.
And, of course, delayed toxicities need structural surveillance programs, and the field is moving, and we have to embrace what is to come and when it's going to be dual and triple target CAR Ts.
On that note, I am done.